this is weird and don't answer this
question if you don't want to matter but
I have to know why you brought this up
but I didn't hear you discuss you had an
extraordinary disagreement with your
wife about yourself do you know what I'm
talking about by myself you mean yes
with interest
one night as you do we were talking
about stuff and of course being
circumcised I said she said she said
you're not circumcised I said what do
you mean you've only known me a few all
my life I remember my mother telling me
why because it was fashionable at the
time she said you're not circumcised I
said that's ridiculous I should know if
I'm conversation but the next day I
happen to be seeing my doctor
I was seeing my doctor on my annual
physical of course so huh while he was
down there by the way disagreement I am
circumcised all right because she says
I'm not and he goes
[Applause]
it's possible so he looked down again
and he said hey I'm Jewish
I know the difference
can is it many times it's not worth
going into over 30 years including when
I asked her about being in this she was
the first person I asked to be on the
train and she very kindly said yes
before I'd finished the sentence and it
was that was very thrilling because it
made a big difference to everybody else
but I used to go and talk to her about
it in our dressing room at the Garrick
Theatre where we were doing
Shakespeare's play at the Winter's Tale
and going into Judy's dressing room was
almost like going into the bookies
because you know she's there I'm
studying Shakespeare like a wild thing
she's bent over the sporting life
I'm going there one night having a
chance it's a very exciting may have
Johnny Johnny Depp maybe in a show and
Michelle Pfeiffer is like Josh catch
each other that's thrilling she was
sitting there with a dressing-gown oh we
get our call over the town Oh mr.
Brannon is thence your Europe you're on
so she gets up we continued talking
great so we're gonna build a train and
it's all gonna be fantastic we get into
the wings ready to go on there's 30
seconds to go she throws off her
dressing gown and there's nothing on
from below the waist
I can confirm like the song there is
nothing like a day but we they're not so
we do so so Judy says dress have to run
all the way back to the dressing room
come back on with it with her skirt and
then she walked on like that and then
all the things she used to do like that
she couldn't do doing the rest of the
scene when somebody acting in semaphore
this was you recently yeah now that's
you in the blue t-shirt and that's right
the white jeans one where are you there
that's in Borneo and in the cave and one
about 200 feet up now add you annoyed
someone done that to you well because I
want to be up there and see all these
there's a million bats Stacy and I
wanted to be there when all the bats
were coming out of the cave so I could
say something like that's a million bats
[Applause]
Kane's face was a picture
I have a question do they go in your
hair then all the scary movies the bats
go on their hair not at all no they've
got all this marvelous thing this system
whereby they got echolocation you know
and actually I've been on that cave
before and and I had to climb up a pile
of bat poo yes I got to the top and I
was sort of choking with ammonia and the
director said hardly out because he's at
the bottom was who say say something see
so I said a lot of people are frightened
about you know and and and the cameraman
was there with a light and he said a lot
of people think they're gonna tackle
your hair not so because of this
echolocation and the camera the director
said cut and the cameraman put the light
out and about hit me straight in yeah
you went 12
yes well what a legend you guys were
married to Joe are you kidding oh my god
gooble the other guests to that lovely
guy 442 yeah that's crazy yeah I think
maybe most of the audience know he did
all the great Pink Panther movies he did
at breakfast at tiffany's and the coast
and and 10:00 and there's kind of movies
but no I had to go topless from but it
was very legitimate and I had it took 10
years super legitimate it was
legitimately in the script is what I'm
there no yes very
you love it is all about it's a real
take off on Hollywood it's a very funny
sob sob is yeah oh no I'm sorry God what
will fed on our wedding night
[Laughter]
[Music]
just tell you don't do this you're
Julianne no no no I mean I'd done an
awful lot by then and I had as I say it
took ten years to get the movie made so
I had ten years to think about it and it
was in the script and quite as I say
legitimate and it just can be cold in
the studio didn't you find that and it's
a lot worse when it's cold for us then
[Music]
but a very busy week what have you been
doing celebrating oh wait a minute
oh I've got so many things really
Michael yeah your birthday
[Applause]
it's a lovely card with a picture of
Michael on the front now is this one
this is one of the talking cards yeah
yeah okay let's listen
[Music]
[Applause]
impressive yeah but the best impression
of my voice I've heard is Tom Hanks
really he did it on the on The Late Show
in in in New York yeah I said I saw him
I was surprised some banks and he never
done it for me do you know this there's
a shortcut to say your name as the way
they listen people say you say my
cocaine yeah
like the drug but loud yeah but I'll
tell you a story about that oh yes I was
I was making a picture in the
Philippines now I'm in Manila and we
were invited to this very very posh
expensive house to a party and I'm being
introduced to people and getting the
drink and all that and the hostess is
standing over there and she's looking at
me rather nastily considering that I'm
the guest you know and I there was a
moment when I was a bit free and she
went so I went over her and she said are
you a drug dealer
I said no why do you ask
she said why is everybody calling you my
cocaine
you know that story it's true that you
couldn't make it out a lot of people at
the party going where's my cocaine
[Music]
you